since Smallville began with the
flashback it's only fitting that it
ended with the Flash Forward while we
got glimpses of Clark's Destiny through
prophecies visions and his trip to the
Future in the 200th episode the final
few moments of Smallville gave us our
best look yet surprisingly that image
comes from a comic book that Chloe reads
to her and Oliver's young son but that's
not all it's here that all the familiar
elements of the Superman Mythos fall
into place Lois and Clark at the Daily
Planet a new Jimmy Olsen by their side
Perry white yelling at Lois Lex Luthor
running for president and Metropolis
again in need of saving this sends Clark
to the roof as the iconic John Williams
Superman March gets louder in the
background while there he rips open his
shirt in classic Superman form an
obvious nod to the Christopher Reeve era
of Superman movies naturally Smallville
ends with Welling Superman Taking Flight
just as we always knew it would